hey there here are all the cinematic
cutscenes in order including a bonus cut
scene in hyrule warriors age of calamity
this does not include narration portion
so some parts may be out of context
also it goes without saying that there
are gigantic spoilers in this but if
you're not worried about that
enjoy your 2 hour movie
oh
i must protect
everyone
so
hmm
listen well soldiers of hyrule in our
long history
we have scarcely faced a threat of this
magnitude
the years have passed quickly since
calamity gannon's revival was prophesied
yes we have unearthed the divine beasts
and
filled volumes with our knowledge of
ancient relics
but a barricade of books will not
protect us
even now the enemy is clawing for our
throat
itself we must exterminate the monster's
roaming hybrid field
thus we'll begin our renewed effort to
stop
the calamity
here now go forth
and be praying for your kingdom
um
you help
huh why is this happening
it's a tower
oh
hmm an inexplicable
garden
and a mysterious tower
i hate to say it but we have little hope
of figuring this out on our own
hey what are you
no stop right there
each of you has served your kingdom
admirably
you made it i'm glad you're safe emperor
yes your highness and i've received the
sheikah slate from pora
what is that
your highness
hmm
why is it so attached to me
whatever could you be little one
i suppose all we can do is wait for
robbie and the others at the lab to
analyze it
agreed your highness
a guardian but why
they're monsters too now of all times
um
this is technology the likes of which
i've never laid
eyes on which means
we've got ourselves a brand new
never-before-witness guardian
devices like the chica slate which are
amplified by the power of such ancient
relics about a meager fragment of such
technology i see that explains why all
of us were able to use the sheikah
slaves
in addition this here hickey is loaded
with
data information
we can't even fathom
oh yeah check it
i extracted some visual data from the
guardian's memory
is that yup
no doubt about it hyrule castle after
calamity ganon has been revived
as you can see we managed to extract
some of the data
but much of it was fragmented
even so if i analyze what we received i
may be able to make sense of more of it
this is the ruin the calamity will bring
upon all of hyrule if we allow this to
pass
i fear all hope will be lost even
everything we've done up until now
likely won't be enough
if i don't succeed at sealing the
calamity
never this will
not come to pass
you intend to let this relic follow you
around
hmm
yes after talking to pura and robbie
we thought it would be best i will
remind you once again
above all else your duty
is of the utmost importance are we clear
yes we are clear i understand
and i will honor my duty
uh
me far pilot the divine beast
yes my father king rome has
faith she will do her utmost with your
permission
of course
this will be a dangerous mission
piloting the divine beast
against the darkness
and i understand
that the knight who will seal
that darkness has not yet
appeared that is true
i must refuse i cannot send my daughter
into such
peril but i your majesty
i bring news
well link you've grown since i last saw
you
and yet you have not changed
this creature is a guardian
how cute princess mifa
monsters on plymouth mountain marching
this way
what of my father his majesty is leading
the army to intercept
he thought the prince was here with you
said on is missing
we will find sidon you must watch over
the domain
highness
uh
why would you try to fight that beast
alone
i was so worried about you
but still i am proud
what a brave little brother i am
oh no
lisa
what is that
ah
there is no turning back now
kingdom
hmm
could it be
this attack proves your point
we are woefully unprepared to defend
against the calamity
will face this peril head on we must
consider the future we all
share this land of high rule
so all of us must do our part
attend yes father
you will become the pilot of the divine
beast
on one condition
you must promise to come back safely
what you'll learn about me is that i
never refuse a sincere request
so of course i'm on board with your plan
except there is one
well problem just varudania is in a
difficult spot right now
the divine beast was found pretty high
up on death mountain
a lot of monsters have been crawling
around lately
so even getting close to old rotani has
a big
pain only the bravest go up there now
so that's why it's a good thing it's
gonna be us
oh um of course come on
death mountain won't climb itself
seeing it again it's even bigger than i
remembered
let's get right to it then
i can't wait
that was unexpected but we pulled
through in the end
you really proved yourself hey little
guy
now about me piloting routania
well go ahead and count the mighty
darukin
oh thank you deruk of course
we'll smash that calamity cannon jerk to
smithereens
oh wait a minute you must be starving
after all that fighting
i know just the cure for that
my favorite prime rock roast
doesn't it look delicious why don't you
dig in little guy
ah sorry how thoughtless of me
i should have brought some for you tiny
princess
next time i promise to bring enough for
everyone
thank you very much
this nonsense again
rito village is my home while i'm here
you won't be getting any closer
yeah you may think you're good
but i'm better stop please
uh
i understand the situation now
i'm thankful no harm befell you either
of you
pardon me
but we must address the gravity of there
being another guardian resembling the
little one your highness
yes if it is in some way connected to
the calamity
we must swiftly come up with a strategy
out with it
we both know you'll be needing my unique
skills
to pilot that divine beast
however
about this pathetic night in your
service
are you sure he's got what it takes
oh i see friend believes itself to be a
night as well
in service of the princess
it what
ridiculous every last one of you
but why why are the guru attacking us
we'll surely be able to explain
everything if we can reach her
ambassador
why what are you doing
thwarting your destiny of course
princess zelda
i came back as quickly as i could
not exactly what i expected to find
i hope you're not hurt little bird
i'm not
you've got some nerve thinking you can
go toe-to-toe with
master pogo
i'll show you
me excluded of course
how could these losers defeat me
i nearly got peeled like a banana
forget these cowards it's time to
retreat
thank you for meeting me here the town
is a bitter
chaotic shall we say of course
we'd meet you anywhere you know about
the
yiga clan i trust
chica traitors working in the shadows to
revive calamity ganon
those lowlifes have been wreaking havoc
here in gerudo canyon
how long can we stand by and watch them
get away with it
no longer i say
i will pilot this divine beast
you are precious to me and you need my
help
i cannot refuse
thank you
as princess of hyrule i too
will carry out my sworn duty
little bird
however i am able to support you i will
just say the word
it seems that as low as my expectations
of you were
well no matter
my harbinger show me the future
the future as it will and must be
i will not allow any to alter its course
his majesty did not offer even a single
word of praise
well it's only natural that father would
be frustrated
but your highness
right now we must do whatever is in our
power
please inform never and daruk that we
depart tomorrow morning
then you plan to go to the divine beasts
understood
father thinks that well he thinks that
the reason my ability hasn't awakened is
because i haven't worked hard enough
i imagine that when i visit the divine
beasts he'll say as much
thank you
the adjustments to the divine beasts are
not yet complete
we must fine-tune them for the
individual pilots to ensure that they
will be as effective as possible
i have a request might i
join you for training next time i would
like to be fully prepared
learning new ways to fight foes might do
me some good
of course the more the merrier
thing is we still need a night gritty
enough to see all the darkness
and they're nowhere to be found
yes although hey if you see anybody that
um
what do they want your highness
i bring news it regards your impending
death
hmm
um
uh
i suppose destiny is at work then
the future is fickle
eager clan time to go
link
um
ah
hyrule's king chose us to perform this
pivotal task it will be
my honor to excel as always
then there's you the one part
that doesn't add up
why should this nobody be trusted to
lead
us in the coming battle
it doesn't matter who's the leader we're
all in this together
right you are of course mistaken
my divine beast is the key
really now it makes no sense
well my one comfort is that your
reputation
will be completely ruined once you fail
the falling night
ravali how long do you expect us to put
up with your prattle huh
i've said enough
the time has come to show you what i'm
made of
now witness vamos divine power
foreign
all clear over here
okay let's go
and they're here
this is quite the fog
are we even making progress we could
just be going in circles
good point if only someone could fly
above and scout the way
as though i could see anything through
this muck
honestly do you ever think before you
speak
getting lost is the least of our worries
something attacked us we wouldn't see it
coming
yes we must be prepared for even the
most unusual
huh
where'd you come from and who
are you oh me i am the one who brings
song and dance to correct forest
let's go
a korok that's great mind guiding us
through the fog then
i'd love to get home myself
but there are scary mean monsters in the
woods
and i can't get past them
you could probably sneak right by if you
didn't have those noisy maracas
oh never mind him we have business in
the forest
if you lead the way we can handle the
mobsters for you
um
yes
hmm
oh
what
uh
yes
great deku tree
all is well the sword you
hold is the key to defeating the
calamity
to sealing the darkness
young hero you have been chosen by the
sword
to wield its power and vanquish
the calamity and you
princess do not
lose hope the pass
will open for you soon
i see
forgive me a deep slumber beckons
and even i cannot refuse
you have all that is needed to face
whatever destiny awaits
fate is
how can i if i am unable
to awaken my inner power
that song
i remember you enemy ahead
link he's become so much stronger
and yet i have not
i presume that's what you're thinking
hmm
more and more monsters have been
appearing lately
it is a sign that the calamity draws
near
so there isn't much time
and still no sign of my power awakening
little bird
perhaps you are missing the point
comparing your progress to lynx
he it's the same boy
he was before acquiring that sword
he will rise to any
challenge with no hesitation that's all
there is to it
in that regard you two are one in the
same
look how hard you've worked to get this
far
well i you see
what did the great deku tree say there's
no need to fret
princess i know
that you are where you need to be
you must accept that too
thank you
we did it we have all the pieces on the
board to stop the calamity
with the knight who seals the darkness
the four champions
and you of course i'm positive we can
turn back
would you stop making a nuisance of
yourself
unlike you the princess is extremely
busy
you cut it out oh now listen you
stop that we're trying to help the
princess here
come on you two there's no need to fight
how dare you act so disrespectfully in
front of her highness
you troublesome teapot so
daruk about what we discussed
ah so you're ready to begin your
training
let's get to it thank you
i hope to become stronger so that i can
fight
oh no i was just um
enough leave me out of this
if you must fight do it i'll say come
back here you whiney little
oh stop it
how asinine
studying relax again
father you think you have time to busy
yourself with things like that
it's just that
this is from a long time ago it's a
relic i found one day while mother and i
were out exploring
mother and i we discussed it at some
length together
it seemed special like it might hold
hidden powers
even after all this time i've yet to
unravel its purpose
but father if you allow me to uncover
the meaning behind such relics
i believe it can help us to enough
that is not for you to determine
it doesn't mean i won't continue with my
training father
but i also want i want to
explore all options to do everything
that i can
even so it seems that you are avoiding
your duty
i will allow it for now
but do not forget your mission
foreign
hmm
so if they can fix that chica
thingamajig
what does that mean for me i mean us
that thingamajig will tell them where we
are
and what we're doing
our cover would be
measures are being taken huh
soon you'll each have your own parts to
play
respect suga this is a directive
this guardian is possessed by calamity
ganon
harbinger of destruction with it
i will bring this world to its knees
you are blind seer
calamity ganon is not for mortals to
control
hmm
huh
ugh
yes you did wonderfully
one down and a whole lot more to go
time's a wasting right
oh what a magnificent view we're so high
up
pura have you found anything yet
i see hmm so by
bonding this with the sheikah slave
what's that
listen princess these towers have got a
lot of power hiding inside
the chica towers were designed to scan
their surroundings for calamity ganon
when we activate them the terminals load
the sheikah slate with a map of the area
you can see the geography nearby and
locate monsters
as easy as click snap so
we can track down the enemy and take
them by surprise
precisely
rather than just telling you about it
why don't i give you a little demo
well it's time
you and i must now ride into battle
without the luxury of training
then again
experience is the best teacher
look what you did
well
i don't mind
i don't mind it
and do you know why
because your thread's about to get cut
and i'm
the shears
hey
the picture today
right now in fact the stupendous chief
of the yiga clan master koga
is gonna kill you all
together
huh hey prophecy man
you miss the part where we get walloped
i am afraid we cannot overlook this
failure
can't do it see her hmm
fate decides all even this defeat
huh as you well know
if you decided to turn against me
you would make an enemy of calamity
ganon
so you see them good
we will need each other's help if we are
to achieve our
grant in the name of calamity ganon you
and i
are bound let us turn our eyes to the
task
before us yes
these chica towers they are
rather useful i admit i know
right oh but just wait there's
one more thing i got gotta show you
would have been nice sorry sorry
but look is this technology amazing or
what
right now we can't teleport many people
at once
and anywho there aren't many places we
can travel but
further study i think these towers will
be invaluable
lucky for us i have lots of new
researchers on my team too
it won't be easy but we're not gonna let
that stop us eh
i know that you won't
i wish i could join you but now
anyway i'm glad for your help kura
are you certain of this yes
zelda's next birthday will mark the date
of calamity gannon's return
yes that is what the images we recovered
indicate at least
time has run out then
zelda you
and the knights will travel to the
spring of courage
no matter what it takes you must awaken
your power
before the calamity returns
understood
i will do whatever i can as i am right
now
even if all i have to give is my faith
that things will work
out this is the thread
that i've been following all this time
even so
all of the research into the relics if i
cannot awaken to my power
will have been in vain everyone else
is carrying out their duties with such
grace
i am the only one who cannot live
up to your own potential
princess zelda
why not let's go take a break somewhere
i've gotten really uh suddenly i'm
really
hungry
emperor
there's just no more time
is everyone all right oh
thank goodness we're all right because
of you princess your keen senses saved
us
well i really it was thanks to your
strength
now you listen to me oh okay
you said that you are the only one who
can't live up to your potential
but that's completely untrue i mean you
saved all of us just now
all of your effort your research is
not in vain princess
thank you empire i want
i will fight to fulfill my duty
until the very end
that's really all i can do i
finally finished my pain staking
analysis
oh yeah
yeah yeah we're all very impressed
now what did you find
stop right there
i was too careless this is bad
so many are awaiting my inner power
believing in me
this is my last chance
princess it'll all work out everything
will just
align at the spring of wisdom
time to head out farewell father
huh
huh the chica slate
something must have happened
i cannot be
no i can't believe it
the calamity is here
well then we seem to have been taken by
surprise
this is bad extremely bad
if the calamity was able to overtake
hyrule castle
uh
uh
father go
now you are the knight
to princess zelda
i trust that you understand your duty
my father stop
let go
my daughter
protector
hello
ugh
the divine beasts ganon
has
i have failed
all of hyrule my friends
even my own father
it's my fault
why won't you awaken for me
everything everything i've done
ultimately all of it was for naught
huh
look up
can we still do this
all is not lost we can still do
something
come on
uh
no way monster
oh this is how it tends
uh
no i will not allow you to take her
again
said
that's my power who are you
don't worry about that i'm here to help
such strength sister please
don't oh you've come at last
huh
ah
stay calm kiddo you're right sir
i will if i came here to save you but
you have to save me
then what's the point yes that's the
spirit
all right let's try that again from the
top
well the deed is done
we should all thank you you really came
through little guy
you know wasn't it i owe you some thanks
too
oh without your help i'd have been in
deep trouble
said on it's all so mysterious
is it truly you my brother yes
it is yours truly
i know this is hard to swallow
but i've journeyed him from the future
none of this makes any sense but oh well
we have bigger rocks to roast
princess tell us
what happened at the castle
i'll tell you
that's why you're the greater i told you
to drop the formalities
sorry but i don't think i can
i'm in trouble
yeah just a scratch
uh
lady armasa
for now let us focus on winning this
fight
vile creature how is it moving like that
i thought i was strong enough to protect
you
listen
you bought us much-needed time now look
who's come to help
huh
is in order
what that thing's still standing yes
and yet i can't help but feel that the
wind may finally be in our backs
now then first i owe you my gratitude
thank you for your help truly
and second read you
you sent could not have prevailed
without your aid
i i would not presume to take credit
we all of us fought as one
well we would have been just fine
without you
but i suppose it's better that you were
here
i never thought the champion would be so
hold that thought for now
little bird please tell us what happened
at hyrule castle
well you see
so
foreign
there he is the champion of the rito
well then i suppose the time has finally
covered
to reveal vomitos divine power
when it happened i could faintly hear a
voice calling to me
as i searched for who it was i suddenly
saw my dear sister under attack
my only thought was that i had to help
her next thing i knew
i was inside beruta
that was your doing wasn't it
thank you
now we must hurry to ocular citadel
what's the problem hurry it up
what's your game free eyes
my you really are slow
despite our best efforts the enemy has
only grown stronger
to succeed we must adjust
our strategy finally
the two of you can actually be of some
use for once
in your life
i can't wait you're my best lackey
in that case i will protect you even if
it cost me my
life a blood sacrifice
for the calamity fate gives you this
role
and you will play it
we don't stand a chance of defeating
them and what's more
our chances of rescue are slim to none
and it's likely the same for all of
heights
and yet rule one the researcher's code
is to
report a divine beast from the western
waters
see that what did i tell you
here we go
we shall cover the perimeter and we'll
join you as soon as we can
sister
we can do this right
side on it's an honor to fight beside
you i'm so
proud of the zorro you've become
remember that
i will
now it's time to focus on the fight
ahead
you're ready for this right
of course sister
this is like a nightmare
you needn't sound so defeated together
we'll put a stop to it
but how look how many there are
i would likely have died if it wasn't
for your courage but i'm still here
and noborus still has its pilot i'd
wager nothing can stop us
exactly
well then let's begin
will you take my hand
hmm
they're not making
we've come so far we must persevere
until the battle is done
by after my own heart you never give in
huh
what took them so long
your thread will be cut here your
highness
impossible
princess come with we can't leave him
i must
i think
that light
oh
everyone hear me now
with calamity gannon now awakened
here we stand at the threshold
of the unimaginable
despite that we must not give in to
defeat
we must not despair
we must stand and fight hyrule wields
the divine beasts and their champions
we are armed with the knight whose sword
will seal the darkness
and we shall strike with you
you brave soldiers everyone
you are mine to leave now
calamity ganon
will be sealed away forever but the
power i possess
together standing in strength we begin
our march
hyrule's fight to rescue all within it
is now
so
well then what did you want to tell me
what are you
huh
all right our fight isn't over
we must hurry i'm sorry your highness
but it's too far even if we left right
away
blah blah blah i just so happen to have
good news to share
go ahead and behold
see that terminal over there i used it
to fiddle with the control unit
the one that's in the castle and of
course
i was successful i managed to reactivate
all of the towers
impressive right
check it let's all hurry to the chica
tower
huh why there i also
upgraded the teleportation functionality
just like that
now that's a feat well to be fair
it's not all me thank the ancient tech
built into our friends
anyway now we should be able to travel
to any tower in hyrule in a flash
or to anywhere really
let us go
uh
father
it is all thanks to this
this little thing saved me
hmm
oh
withdrawal
your heart your boundless compassion
with those precious gifts
you have saved my life
while i accused you of evading your duty
in truth perhaps i was guilty of the
same
forgive me
that's not
father you've always loved me
everything you've done has always been
for me
the burden the heavy load you've shorted
all this time
from now on please let me help you carry
it
zelda you are my pride
and indeed the pride of all
i rule with your power
i believe you will seal away calamity
cannon now
let us rally our forces for a final push
troops from all regions shall gather at
hyrule
field
alongside our princess we will retake
hyrule castle
i understand your fear
but with all of us together we shall
prevail
the time has come
look over here
thank goodness it looks like it went
well
all that is left to do is to join up and
destroy ganon
and finally it's our chance to flaunt
our power in all its splendor
make us proud master revoli
all right everybody let's go get our
sweet revenge
yes sir let's do this
i never imagined things could go this
way awaiting your orders
calamity ganon we'll be brought to its
ruin
hyrule is our home and we must band
together
to protect and defend it
divided our strength would never have
been enough
but together all of us
united in our great power
together we are unstoppable we shall
overcome this threat
now to the castle
we must
and now link it's up to us
dannon's magic works is strongest
huh is that so
here you all are
all of you despicable pests
but that looks like
will crush you beneath my heel
that is my face
ah
how the great calamity ganon
selected me this humiliation
cannot be my destiny it cannot be
hear me calamity ganon it's time for you
to devour these peace
it's done
mother look look
mother
you are not going to leave me too right
dereko
father no please don't take it away
the return of the calamity has been
foretold
as the princess of hyrule your sole
focus must be
on your training a toy such as this
is merely a distraction please
please
i'm sorry
jericho
uh
calamity ganon
the sake of hyrule
for all those harmed and slain
for our future
this is where you fall
yes
is
wow
no more
it is time
to end this
you can do it little guy
don't screw this up
well then it seems the time has come
i could not be prouder it was an honor
to be of service
i know you'll lead our people well greet
you
thanks for everything you know we didn't
get much time together
but i'll always cherish it i will too
it was so much fun you're the best
this has been enlightening i even got to
see the face behind the champion
i know that we'll meet again dear
brother
yes you're my beloved sister
and our hearts will never be apart
i will never forget today's miracles
how all of you fought by my side and the
trials we overcame together
and now as you return to your future
may the light shine upon you for all
time
that doesn't
yeah hold your horses champ because
i mean i don't think it's working at all
was there something we didn't do you've
done all
you could the results will surely
reflect that
calm down the thing's probably just
stretching out it's not
yeah i'm in agreement with rivali
well come on you wakey wait right now
stand back
oh
welcome home jericho
oh
do
hmm
you